the nfts is really just a proof of
ownership where can this thing go next
it's something that i think is going to
be around for for quite a while we've
barely scratched the server
most people still have no clue what a
bitcoin is
well kids hate corporations do you see
any
regulatory or the government getting
involved like we saw with gamestop
those rules can change on a dime and
it's like oh
here's a new rule don't like it go
yourself
[Music]
so i want you to think about one day you
wake up and you start working with these
things called nfts and you designed this
one thing called nft you name it the
everyday
serious nft and you you go into auction
with it
on february i want to say what is it
26th
you go on auction with it and a few days
later on march 11th
this thing goes from a hundred dollars
which was day one february 26th the
auction started at 100
on march 11th with exactly
one hour and 18 minutes left it's at
14.75 million dollars you're sitting
there with your family your kids
everybody in the living room
and the auction ends at 69
million dollars your name is
mike winkelmann aka people that is
my guest today mike thank you so much
for joining us on valuetainment
thank you so much for having me super
honored to talk and
and uh yeah it has been a bit of a
whirlwind
bit of a whirlwind but yeah it's um
still processing but it's it's really
exciting being able to talk to people
about
you know my work and this new technology
because i really feel like this
well this might be the first time you've
heard of nfts i really do not think it
will be the last
well i want to get into that i
definitely want to get into that so all
of us can get more educated about but
the day you were sitting at the
house and you're watching this being
done at 69 million
who in your family was in the room who
said
mike you're wasting your time what the
hell are you working on
who's somebody are you flipping kidding
me or did everybody kind of know you're
up to something big
nobody uh so the
um in the room there was two camera
crews
i was on clubhouse with a couple
thousand people on clubhouse so it was
not
super private um but my entire family
was
on it uh uh in the room and they have
been
extremely extremely supportive for from
day one of this project
and day one of this project was may 1st
so well i just sold this thing for 69
million this is
literally a project that one single
picture was a project that took me
13 years to do um it encapsulates the
everyday's project which is basically a
picture that i do
every single day from start to finish
that day and sort of post it online and
that's something that i've done i did
last night i'll do today
and it's something that i've been doing
for the last over 13 years
so it's 5 000 days starting may
what was it you said may 1st 2007 and
then the last the 5 000th
day was january 7th 2021.
and and who knew that you were doing
what like did the nfd community know
that you're doing this every day that's
coming up to 5000
like was it an event that people were
behind it and they were looking forward
to it or was it a very exclusive small
event that was
following this no so that's one thing i
think a lot of people because
this is a lot of people sort of first
exposure to me and it's like oh people
and know this is who is this guy blah
blah blah
i've been doing this and was actually
kind of one of the most popular
designers in the world before this like
i had almost 2 million followers on
instagram
before i even knew of nfts so i was a
very very popular
designer before this and that's kind of
why like
many like literally millions of people
know about this every day's project
it's just in the traditional art world
and sort of the mainstream media
you know i was not very well known
obviously um
but yeah it's definitely like i've
worked on the last couple super bowls
the like you know halftime show
graphics i did a big collaboration with
louis vuitton they used the everydays on
the front of the clothes and stuff
so you know this is a project that has
you know many many thousands tens of
thousands millions of people
like know about before this it's just
you know the nft thing is
you know a new way to actually sell this
stuff and so that's where you sort of
saw this
this you know big explosion of money and
and sort of you know interest now
well let me ask you this because you
sold crossroads november 2020 which was
just a few months ago for 66 thousand
dollars
the buyer bought it and resold it
on february 26 for 6.6 million dollars
so when you sold crossroads on november
20 november 2020 for 66 000
did you in that moment when you sold it
for 66k think that every days could
potentially sell for
69 million or did you have a number in
your mind
for half a mill i think it'll sell 4
million there's no way it's selling for
70 million
no so what happened so again i've been
sort of a popular designer in the like
digital art community for
for you know years a decade um
and so growing a following there and
sort of you know getting better and
better sort of like client jobs
and so last fall a bunch of people kept
hitting me up about this nft thing and
again i'm very new to this too like i
only learned of this
in like mid october of last year so this
isn't something i've been you know deep
into crypto and all this stuff for years
that is not me i was a uh you know i've
been around digital art for a very long
time
but i have not been around this stuff so
people kept hit me up be like oh you
gotta look at these nfts you gotta like
look at these nfts or something here
and so when i did it was like oh my god
like
you're selling a video clip like i
didn't even think you could do that
much less people are paying like you
know really good money for this stuff
and again i looked at sort of the people
who were in the space already and it's
like okay well to be honest i'm actually
more popular than all these guys like
i'm probably gonna do pretty good here
um and so the first sale that i did
um there was a couple pieces um and yeah
the crossroads he sold for 66 000
which again you know i i was a well-paid
designer
not like you know no designers paid that
well for
one clip that they spend you know a day
or two on that they get 66
000 so that seemed like a massive amount
of money
that it's like okay this is sort of like
if i do a few of these a year
and each one takes two days like there's
my year like that's pretty good money
you know
and so it seemed like a huge amount of
money at the time
and then in december i did another drop
another sort of collection and that one
sold 3.5 million
and that was just like you know broke
all the like records
everybody's freaking out oh my god this
is crazy 3.5 million
just destroyed all the records in the
space at the time
um and so even at the beginning of this
year like
fast forward to the beginning of this
year it was like well
you know there's a lot of predictions
like so you know an nft is going to sell
for a million dollars this year like
that was like a big prediction in the
space like somebody's gonna finally
break a million dollars for one nft
and so even at the beginning of the
christie's auction it was like
i don't know like i sold one piece for
like 700 000 like i think this could
sell for over a million
um so then from there the expectations
just kind of kept ramping up and like
you know
it just got completely crazy here
and so that kind of that's how we are
like you know came to this moment
and and this massive massive sale what's
great about your story is the fact that
you didn't expect this to be taking
place that's the best part of
artists and creatives by the way i saw
stat the other day
you're the third most expensive living
artist alive today
like i mean that is insane when you
think about it right 69 million dollars
and
are you back at it are you back at it
again when you're doing another 5 000
are you working
on another thing like that today yeah i
mean the the the everyday's project
again this like is something that
started well before
um you know i knew of nfts this was uh
you know it was just like okay i want to
get better at art and so
it started as a way to to get better at
drawing and so i did a drawing every day
for the first
uh you know year i saw an illustrator
out of the uk who did a sketch a day for
for like a year and it was like oh
that's a really cool idea
i could use that to get better um and so
that's why i started it to get better
and that's why i'm still doing it
because i still feel like there's a
massive massive amount of room for
improvement and that's why i'll do it
today that's why i'll do it tomorrow
next day blah blah so
to me honestly the everyday's project is
much bigger than this like nft thing and
it's something that
right now i plan on doing for the rest
of my life and so
we're 13 years in here i'm 39 i feel
like hopefully
god willing i've got a few more years to
keep doing this so
i really feel like we're not even you
know sort of close to
being done i'm very very very far from
being done with this
um and yeah it sorry do you know the
buyer that bought it like do you know
metacogne like have you guys met each
other have you guys spent time together
or no
no no we never met each other because
again like so
all this stuff was like you know
auctions and buyers and collectors and
blah blah that's not part of that was
not part of being a digital artist you
did freelance work
you sort of a client came to you here's
the work give me the money here's the
gone to the next thing like that's all
there was there was no like
because without nfts there was no way to
really prove you own these things
and so like yeah i never met him i
talked to him on like
zoom before just because he had bid
actually on
some of my earlier stuff so i was like
okay well you know he
he obviously seems like somebody who's
interested in my work
so i reached out to talk to him before
the december sale and then he actually
ended up buying a big chunk of that
stuff in the december sale
yeah apparently he bought 20 images for
combined 2.2 million
yep and then which is uh he later
fractionalized currently those works
have a market cap of 163 million
yeah so from 2.2 million to 163 million
in a span of three months he so he's not
doing bad for himself
and then that was actually a span of
like a month and a half because he
bought those and then it took him a
little time to fractionalize him so he
didn't even do that until like
i think like january like end of january
and like
him doing that too like this whole thing
is such a rabbit hole like so he bought
those in december
bought all of them and he actually
bought them in secret like he kind of
like created a bunch of like
like pseudo names and like throughout
the the the course of the weekend when
all the auctions because it was like 20
auctions
and after a few auctions people are like
i think this is like
i think somebody's buying all these like
the same person's buying them
because he named them after like greek
hills
the like all these names and then he put
like aetherium into these different
wallets and created all these different
accounts and like tricked everybody
and so by the end it was like oh i
bought all of them and it was just
everybody was just like what like that's
crazy or whatever
and so then is medicovan a a well-known
person in the business world or no quiet
not to me i don't i don't think he's
that well known at all
um and so um
yeah he he kind of we jumped on a zoom
call like a week or two after the thing
and he's like you know this is what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna like fractionalize it
like do that it's like wait
what like i was i was honestly against
it at first it was definitely like okay
i don't i don't really like that dude i
don't know about that like
that's not really what i intended and i
was kind of like really like
i don't know dude this is like super
weird like
what are you doing and so i was no no
it'll be fine it'll be fine it's like
okay well i mean it's you bought it like
for one i can't stop you you seem to be
really
confident in this and like it was sort
of one of these things where it's like
i'm not just not going to explain it to
any of my fans because it's sort of like
they barely understand what nfts are now
it's this crazy weird fractionalization
thing that's even more down the rabbit
hole it's like okay dude if you could do
it and sell it to your
other crypto friends like go for it but
like
i'm not gonna try and sell this thing
again i already sold it once
and so he's like no no i'll handle
everything it's all good and so it's
like okay
and so he like gave me like two percent
of the shares and was like okay
cool um and sort of then fractionalized
it and
you know and it sold out immediately but
it didn't go way off right at first
and then slowly over when the christie's
things announced then it popped up to
like a hundred million it was like
just crazy so yeah he's predicting that
your
the everyday series is now worth a
billion dollars that's what his
prediction is
well he's gonna certainly try and make
it worth a billion dollars and
again like that seems good for me too if
he can do that and that's one of the
things that i think is super interesting
about nfts is
it does allow you to sort of
fractionalize ownership like this
really easily um versus with a painting
you can do that there's masterworks and
there are some other places where they
have kind of fractionalized ownerships
of okay a picasso or something like that
but they're very illiquid for one and
they're um it's just much harder to set
up
and it's just not as sort of transparent
versus with the blockchain
it's all very transparent and you can
see he's actually sold
none of those shares um and so
it's just it's much much easier to do so
i think this this idea of fractionalized
ownership over you know
more expensive artwork that's something
you're going to see and sort of a a very
new
interesting trend you know way to buy
art
now now mike has your lifestyle
tremendously change after getting the 69
million dollars or not right now it's
only been four days i don't what am i
even gonna do in four days i don't even
know it's like
uh yeah we did and we did take uh
this weekend we took a private jet down
about but miami
um which i never i've never even flown
first class
i've never flown out of here i never i'm
telling you
i thought it was just kind of like okay
it's just like uh
it always seems way too expensive and
like i was you know
too much of an idiot to just put that in
the contracts when people were flying me
places that it's kind of like nah i
don't need it
and it's sort of like it honestly
doesn't seem to appeal to me that much
somehow seats are a little bit bigger
whatever um
but i will say the private jet was quite
nice
[Laughter]
good for you you know again there are
stories where people want to see
people win your story is that kind of a
story so now that we know your story
let's get into
nfts look most people
still have no clue what a bitcoin is
what blockchain is most people still
have no idea so
why don't you explain it in your words
when you think about blockchain
then go to cryptocurrency hypothetically
bitcoin ethereum whatever it is explain
that
then go to nft so give me a series of
educating each
then leading into nfts sure so the
blockchain is basically just a series of
sort of like
look at it like a big spreadsheet where
everybody can like add
rows to it and everybody agrees on this
spreadsheet so everybody kind of agrees
okay this is what's happened
these are all the transactions and this
is what's happened so
what that allows you to do is have
something like a bitcoin
and you can't just copy and paste it
because everybody else will be like
no no no you can't do that that's not
part of the rules
so with bitcoin again you can't just
okay i've got one
copy and paste now i've got two like
that's not how it works that's why
bitcoin actually has value
and nfts are very similar to that there
exist
on the blockchain it's another thing
sort of written to the blockchain in
this case it's an
ethereum which is a different blockchain
than sort of
bitcoin there's there's multiple
different blockchains
um basically like multiple different
sort of spreadsheets that everybody's
kind of agreeing on
and with ethereum you can also sort of
program in rules for how these sort of
like
you know things on the blockchain work
so you can put little programs on top of
the like tokens and stuff
so the nfts is really just a proof of
ownership
it's really just proving you own this
token on the blockchain and the
the token itself can kind of point to
different things it's kind of say okay
well this token
points to a picture this token points to
a video
this token points to a thing and and
just like uh with bitcoin
you can prove you are the only person
that owns it and you can't just copy and
paste and okay now i've got two of them
so it is a very hard it is a very sort
of um
you know different sort of paradigm from
what we've been used to with digital
whereas with you know digital and and
the internet and computers
we're used to you copy a file you copy
another here's another copy here's
another copy
we can just make a million copies all
day nobody knows where the first one was
they're all completely identical who
cares no you can't own it you're just
it's just out there and you make another
copy and
so it is a bit you know sort of hard
to kind of wrap your head around and it
is a different like sort of like
paradigm shift but i think once people
do
they'll realize that it's sort of um
it's really similar to owning
a bunch of different things that
there's different analogies for for
owning something virtual
and sort of applying value to that that
that already exists so say like an mp3
um you know you could have a million
copies
of sort of you know michael jackson's
thriller but that's very different from
the person who owns the master recording
and so when you have a copy of it nobody
thinks
oh okay well you own thriller like of
course you don't
like you don't own the master recording
and so that's what it's kind of like
with this
anybody can download a copy of my
picture
but that doesn't mean you own it because
you don't own the token
that says you own the picture well then
that's a follow-up so here's a follow-up
question that comes on that so sure
if you own the master of michael jackson
or beatles or whoever they are which
elvis presley those are pretty valuable
you know masters to own if i play that
song
on a video youtube would flag it and
bring you back and say you have to pay
these guys xyz
if i listen to the song i have to pay 99
cents to itunes or buck 29.
if i buy an album i have to pay 30 bucks
or whatever it may be right
if you own if you own every days yep
and somebody else decides to use it does
the how do you monetize
the master of that nft that you own
it's it is a little different it's not
exactly like that it's more just about
sort of like owning like a painting it's
it's more
in that case it's sort of like there's a
bunch of copies but it's more like
owning a painting where
it's sort of like it's not as quite as
easy to sort of directly monetize like
that because there is no way to stop
people from like sharing this stuff
um so that's not a perfect analogy but
it's one analogy that kind of shows that
a bunch of people can own a copy but
then one person can own sort of the like
this is the person who owns it well a
bunch of copies still exist
so let's talk about the painting so if
it's a painting and
i come to your house and i say mike wow
what is that painting you say it's a
video it's whatever you tell me i'm like
oh my gosh
when it was painted in 1973 before etc
he was going through a divorce and
he died nine years later so essentially
this is his last whatever okay
unbelievable what'd you pay for this 70
million bucks unbelievable man enjoy it
but with this one here i don't really
have a place to put it on there right
because
i can i can put every days as a digital
on a
120-inch screen tv in my house and say
look at what mike built together this is
beautiful
but i don't own it how is the element of
art being appreciated for the work that
you did
during those 5 000 days yep so i think
it is
that is true and that's another part of
ownership that is very different here
because
in the past a big piece of ownership was
restricting
access so in that case you just talked
about
you had to go into that guy's house he
had to let you into his house
to see this painting that's not what
this is it's
really just about proving ownership so
it that's another thing that's a little
bit hard for people to wrap their heads
around because in the past it's sort of
like
if you wanted to own something online
the way you showed that is you put it
behind a paywall
you said no you need to give me money
first to see it
that's not what this is it's really
about kind of the opposite of that
actually the more popular this painting
this
picture gets the more valuable it will
be
sort of an example of that is you go
into the loo and you take a picture of
the mona lisa
and you share that online well you just
made another copy of the mona lisa
available do you think that makes the
mona lisa
less valuable because you did that no
of course not like it's a little like
absolutely not
it's the most it is the most valuable
painting because it's the most famous
painting
that's the thing and that's what if
we can if i can make this and manikova
can make this the most famous painting
then it will be the most valuable
painting and so that's
that's kind of like what this is it's
sort of like it's not about
sort of restricting people's access to
it it's just about proving
who owns it so in the case that you said
um you know
this thing how is how are people gonna
see it how are they gonna experience it
well we're gonna try and get it in
museums all over the world and here's
the advantage that something digital has
is it doesn't have to take just one form
that's right like when you have a
painting
that guy your buddy's painting one
person there's only one painting
it's locked away in his house nobody's
enjoying it nobody's seeing it
and with this uh it can take a bunch of
different
forms and it can take a bunch of
different forms over time
so i can make a a copy of it for medic
clothing bag here
i'm gonna make a big print for you and
your house this is just for you here's a
copy of it
and then we're going to make a
installation in this museum and we're
going to you know get a bunch of
projectors and make a big huge
massive massive projection and that's
going to be in this san francisco museum
then we're going to have this this
museum in hong kong they've got a bunch
of screens we're going to put a bunch of
screens in this thing and we're going to
make a copy of it there
so this artwork because it's digital
could actually exist in
a bunch of different places at the same
time and we have people experiencing it
and viewing it and each one could be
slightly different too
so it's something where uh there are
some advantages like that
to to um you know digital artwork
because again at the end of the day
it has to come into the physical world
somehow so
whether that's on a computer screen
whether that's on a phone
you are viewing it in the real world
somehow so
i think that's that's a huge advantage
of it can take a bunch of different
forms
but then the nft is still sort of the
kind of piece of it that kind of
that is the actual sort of artwork does
that make sense it is again it's a it's
a bit hard
a different way of looking at it so then
here's the question that follows up that
because
it says uh the last 30 minutes of the
auction witnessed a rare phenomenon of
last-minute bids which skyrocketed price
of 69 million dollars people's
work also brought a new class of
collector to the century's old auction
house of 33 active bidders you had 33
active bidders
91 of them were new to christie's people
who know christie's they know christie's
but if 91 are new to christie's they
don't know christie's they just came to
christie's
and most majority were millennials and
gen x buyers made up of made up the
majority
christie said in a press release most
bidders were in the americas
followed by europe and asia so here's my
question i don't know if you know the
answer to this question
where most of your buyers or bidders
folks who are heavy or made their money
in the bitcoin world that kind of want
to be low-key and nobody knows meaning
are these art collectors bidding or are
they
bit exactly that's exactly they're
crypto people you're 100
right i got it they're absolutely crypto
people and so that honestly
and what that was one of the first
questions when i came to this space like
who the hell are these people bidding on
this
and like why because this seems very
speculative
and it's like yeah it is very
speculative but these are crypto people
and if you made a lot of money in crypto
it's because you bet on crypto early
when it was quite speculative
and it was sort of like this bitcoin you
know if you made a bunch of money on
bitcoin it's not because you bought
bitcoin you know three months ago
it's but you because you bought bitcoin
ten years ago
eight years ago when everybody was like
what is this stupid crap this
is they're just paying for internet
money okay
great you're idiots and you were like
nah i'm gonna bet on
and you speculated it was it was not
anywhere proven at that time
and so now these people started
speculating on this
nft stuff and so that's where where it
is
they are new uh customers they are new
people and that's where i think this
digital art
and nfts is going to bring in a massive
massive amount of new customers who
never thought of themselves as
collecting art
they look at art and it's like okay i
don't know what the hell that is
i don't give any about like what
that is it looks super weird it doesn't
connect with me at all
i'm a young guy or whatever that made
money on the internet
and sort of that does not speak to me i
don't know what it is i don't really
care about that
i'm not interested in buying that um and
so that's where i think this is going to
bring in a whole new group of collectors
um to to collecting art that that you
know
never would have thought of it before
and and that's huge for christie's to be
quite honest
it's huge for a lot of this stuff 100 oh
yeah absolutely
there's those people you know i hate to
say it no offense to them but like
they're dying
like they're so old that they're dying
because it's old money
but there's a lot of new money out there
there's a lot of new money that made
money on the internet that's exactly it
and those people are gonna want art too
and that's where i think this digital
art is going to speak to them
in a much much more sort of visceral way
uh than the old heart did yeah i mean
look i think what is happening right now
the question then becomes can they
convert and sometimes the converting
takes a little longer right for others
to uh
say you know what this is the way to go
listen i don't care if you like it or
not the internet's here i don't care if
you like it or not
i know you don't want to post your
picture mom on facebook but everyone's
doing it
you know and now she did it everyone's
doing snapchat so
i think that has anybody weird contacted
you since the sale meaning an elon musk
or any of those has anybody
or the white house have you been in
contact with anybody
of extreme power that's like wait a
minute what the hell just happened can
you fill us in
on what you can say about nfts um i mean
i've talked to a lot of people before
that i talked to mark cube and i've
talked to gary vee
um you know i've talked to a bunch of
people who we are kind of like
what is going on here obviously i've
been on you know a ton of shows and
stuff um
but yeah i think it's honestly it's it's
still so early in this that that people
aren't
really understanding where this is going
or where it could go um and i think
it's it's very i think at these prices
too to be quite honest it's it's almost
very easy to
dismiss as like crazy crazy hype that
it's just like well what is this come on
like there's no way it's worth that much
um and i think it it is very
um you know that there is some level of
like kind of like a bubble here
that i think it's it's there is you know
some level of like
and we're getting a bit jacked up here
but i i think it's
what i think what i would say to that is
there was a big bubble with the internet
and
uh you know there was a lot of people
who are super jacked up about the
internet and they were paying crazy
crazy amounts of money
and then the bubble burst but the bubble
did not kill the internet
people kept using the internet because
the internet was useful and that is what
i believe will happen with nfts
i think it's going to be you're going to
see a bunch of people rush in and
okay nft of a toothbrush
nfg everything um but the technology is
is simple enough in a way and strong
enough in a way that i think it's going
to outlast that and all the crap's going
to get wiped out
and you know the amazons the googles the
blah blah blah they'll still be around
the people's if you will but
you know what i mean i think it's one of
these things where people need to be
careful it is still very speculative but
it's it's something that i think is
going to be around for for quite a while
because it has a lot of use cases
and we barely barely scratched the
surface
blockchain people know that but it will
take a bit longer like to your original
point it will take a bit longer for
everybody else to kind of come around to
it
yeah so so you know the younger
generation historically have always been
the biggest baptizers
they baptized they eventually baptized
the older generation
it takes longer to baptize the older
generation
than it does to baptize the younger
generation because eventually they're
like listen mom
whether you understand this stuff or not
your son is worth 17 million bucks what
do you want to do you know you want to
kind of like understand that this works
or and did you know my son did you know
that guys did you know her son did you
know johnny's
moms you know did you so those stories
eventually go and people start
kind of uh um looking at it saying maybe
this may be the direction to go so a few
different things
jack dorsey puts out his tweet right i
don't know what he sold it for but he
sold it for 20 okay two and a half
million dollars
he sold his first tweet as an nft yeah
you hear
other stories like that elon musk is
talking about he's gonna make a song
yeah he made it yeah he made a song and
i offered him 69 million for it
yeah i offered him 60 million dollars
for his song and he kind of
and then he decided he wasn't going to
sell it
so so what do what do you think what do
you think this thing can go with nfts
like
can can can you own a digital
dream house in an nfd that's worth 10
million bucks can you own a
digital home in mars where it's like
look at this you know waterfront
property on mars and you kind of make it
as an imaginative place
what what where can this thing go next i
think you could do all those things
it's more like will everybody want to do
those things it's you could again you
could attach it to anything
it's sort of like you need to get
everybody to actually want to pay that
much
if if you're saying it's 10 million
dollars then you've got to convince
people that it's worth 10 million
dollars it's got to be
in some game or something that's very
very popular that everybody's like
everybody wants that thing so obviously
twitter
probably not going anywhere it's kind of
a big thing so
the founder of twitter his first tweet
it's kind of like well that kind of
seems like it's a piece of internet
history
you could very strongly argue that
that's a pretty sort of like big piece
of internet history
honestly 2.5 million dollars for that
does not i'm not sure it actually sold
for that i think that's current bill
bid uh i i believe that will go much
higher than that because that is a
massive massive part of internet history
um and so i think it's one of these
things where
there's a lot of things that we connect
value to that do not have
any inherent value look at a baseball
card everybody agrees you have a mickey
mantle you know 18-0
whatever i don't know what the hell you
know a mickey mantle rookie card
that's worth something well why it's
just a piece of cardboard
well you're gonna pay this much for a
little piece of cardboard what are you
talking about it's what it
symbolizes and so just like with jack
dorsey the first tweet
it's like what does that symbolize when
you when you
pay you know a million dollars for a
baseball card and you're like well i
really want that cardboard
no it's what the cardboard needs and so
the painting is really no different it's
a piece of stretch cloth with some paint
on it well why does that happen why
would i pay for that
that doesn't have any like value or
meaning it's it's the cultural relevance
it's the historical relevance it's like
there's a bunch of symbolic meaning that
we attach to things
that you know we're going to start
attaching to digital goods because again
those digital goods have just as much
cultural relevance
just as much historical value as
anything that's you know
a physical thing so so for example the
other question would be you know how
lebron james dunk
sold for whatever 220 i don't know the
number was 208 or 220.
yep if a per the person who bought that
that doesn't mean espn or the lakers can
never show the highlights of that
yep they do if that becomes like the
most famous dunk ever where it's like
that's michael
jordan freaking boom or that's one of
these just the most
iconic dunks then that thing will be
worth a lot
if in you know three years from now five
years from
10 years from now he's done a million
sweeter dunks and nobody gives a crap
about
that dunk then it will not hold that
value
it's how much people will care about
this stuff in the future
do you think people will still care
about twitter in the future
then that first tweet might be worth a
lot but if nobody's gonna give a
about twitter
in the future then yeah it's not worth
anything so
it's it is it it it's about how much how
relevant these things are
in the future that's what's gonna give
them value crazy question for you would
you buy nfts or have you bought any nfts
yourself or no
i have not bought any nfts there are
ones that i would buy
i just honestly i've been so like
focused on like getting
you know sort of uh getting my own stuff
going i haven't really like messed with
it honestly i haven't done
very much of any investing with the
money that i've gotten from any of this
stuff just because i've been so
you know heads down on making the next
thing but there are definitely ones
crypto punks
they're crypto punks are actually the
first nfts those i believe are going to
be worth a huge amount moving forward
because they were actually the very
first ones
and they're these weird little sort of
pictures of these they're very sort of
simple looking
um those i believe will absolutely hold
value and will be like
massive massive in the future but and
this is a
big but a lot of the nfts right now
will not be worth anything in the future
it is still
very very speculative it is something
that is
um it is not for like okay you know
this is for people who who you know are
willing to take a bit more risk because
it is definitely definitely more risky
than like you know
buying a share of of amazon or microsoft
or whatever
so so do you the the risk to this before
we wrap up the downside to this downside
to this
do you see any regulatory or the
government getting
involved to hurt or slow down or
challenge what nfts because the moment
you see that kind of money coming in you
can all of a sudden see the
all the you know you know people coming
and say hey you guys got to create some
rules you guys got to create some loss
is that a possibility that could slow it
down or that wouldn't have any effect on
it regardless
no i mean a government come in and make
rules around anything there's
absolutely nothing that will stop that i
in this case i don't think they will
just because it's actually quite sort of
cut and dry in a way it is so simple
that it's just sort of like okay you're
buying the like
token and that's kind of it so i i don't
know that
they i personally don't think they will
or if they did i don't know what those
rules would look like
um again you don't know what the
government they could always come in and
screw things up they'll find a way
they'll find a way to screw things up so
they could it personally i would not be
super i'm not super concerned about that
so final thoughts here somebody's
watching and saying mike you've inspired
me man i'm gonna go
uh uh uh either buy or i'm gonna go be a
designer it's like
that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna set
it up what would you tell the creative
kind of like you if you could give any
feedback to the creative
who's like you if i would have done
three of those per year 66 000
i'm fine with the lifestyle that i have
that would have been great not 69
million
what feedback you got for the creatives
and what feedback you have for those
that are saying
i'm not fully comfortable with
blockchain i am sitting on a million
dollars i wouldn't mind investing in a
little bit of the blockchain
nfts that's coming out what do you
suggest me doing give me feedback to
both the creative
and the investor to the creative i would
say start in every days and i and there
have been
literally you know sort of tens of
thousands of people who have started
every day
because of like me seeing me do this and
some of those people have
hundreds of thousands of followers in
their own right so this is very much
like a movement
in you know i've been bugging people to
start every days for
many many years and a ton of them have
and it's something that is you know sort
of a known sort of movement
in digital art doing every days um so
yeah i would recommend doing that and
again
i would not sort of focus on the money
piece of it the money aspect of it focus
on getting better
and uh the money will come or it might
not come
but like you can't control that piece of
it that piece of it is very hard
what you can control is how much you sit
your ass down and you like practice and
work your ass off
that you can very much control and it's
about just putting in the work every
single day
there there's no shortcut to it like
there's no
fancy oh here's you know some advice
that you never heard that somehow is
some shortcut no no
it's just the work that's all it is it's
just about load of work like there's no
other
you know way around it um to the
investor
i would say if you want to get into nfps
i would look at those crypto punks
i would also look if there's this guy
named beeble who makes awesome artwork
no i would say i i think it's one of
those things where you really need to
sort of do your due diligence
um look at this stuff try and understand
the space more um
and sort of have it on your radar i
think it's going to get
more and more you know an alternate
asset class that i think people
are it's going to get more and more
viable i think we've sort of
you know kind of gotten used to the idea
that
you know equities have been the
predominant asset class for the last 100
years
you throw up you get a little extra
money and you choose a corporation and
you give that money to corporations well
kids hate corporations
they super hate corporations and so this
idea that they're just gonna
automatically grow up get a couple extra
bucks and you know give it to amazon
give it to google
give it to blah blah blah i don't know
that i see that just
automatically continuing forever and so
if there's alternate asset classes like
nfts like bitcoin something like that i
could see those being a real sort of
you know alternative that people would
like to sort of like well i'd rather buy
a people than i would you know put it
into
berkshire hathaway so i think it's one
of these things that you know
could be really important growing up
because the other part of it is you have
much more of a sense of digital
ownership of these
and you can sort of you know do them and
trade them and sort of own them
with with much less rules and much less
oversight again you go back to stocks
you have to trade at a certain time a
certain way
certain places you know there's a lot of
rules around it and those rules
like we saw with gamestop those rules
can change on a dime
and it's like oh here's the new rules
don't like it go yourself
this is the new rules kids didn't like
that nobody liked that
and so if you have something like this
that has less rules and it's
you have more of a sense of ownership
which again people are yearning for that
online
you go to you know you give your data to
facebook and google you stop owning it
they own it then
you've given it to them and so this is
another thing where you have much more
of a sense of ownership which is not
something we're used to online we're
used to giving people stuff and then
they own it and they do whatever the
hell they want with it
that's not what this is and so this is
where i think it could be
you know a massive massive alternate
asset class moving forward
people hate kids hate corporations
try to give them money what a great way
of putting it
and explaining it very eloquent by the
way mike who were you in high school if
i'm in 11th grade with you or 16 years
old who was mike
uh i was just i was i don't even know
i was just kind of it's funny because i
actually just went to a high school
literally like a couple hours ago
to get a uh vaccine first shot or
whatever
and i was kind of thinking about high
school i was just literally a couple
hours ago and it was kind of like
it occurred to me how i was like high
school was just like four years where it
just kind of
happened then it was like whatever i
don't it didn't really
were you to 4.0 gpa 4.5 no i actually
i do remember this i got voted in my
class and i think this was partially
because people just didn't know me that
good and there was just like okay
there's a few awards left over let's
give it to him whatever that him
i got voted most most lazy
get out of here dad serious that serious
again i think it was partially you were
just like okay there's six awards left
there okay get my
most lazy who gets the crap but yeah i
was i will say i was lazy i definitely
was lazy i think
maybe people saw i was a bit smarter
that my grades were not reflecting that
i could probably have tried a bit harder
i will say that
well kudos to you what a great story you
got i'm definitely following your story
and i'm looking forward to seeing bigger
things happen with you
uh you seem sincere just a guy that all
of a sudden went from
being an artist to selling something for
69 million dollars mike
wish you nothing but the very best thank
you for being a guest on valuetainment
i appreciate that you got it buddy take
care awesome thank you
69 million dollars think about a 69
million dollars because he stuck to it 5
000 days from may 1st
2007 to january 7 2021
and it sells at christie's auction for
million dollars and how he broke down
nfts hey kids hate
corporations they they're going to be
more excited about something else
investing into an art
and what direction this is going to go
comment below i want to hear your
thoughts and we had a debate this last
week on the podcast
if nfts are a fad if you haven't heard
that yet click over you to watch that
take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye